you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chest gum
and I just got paired up playing against
Rodrigo 21 all righty
let's go with a d5 hmm all right I'm
gonna shoot for a quick c5 I'm not gonna
try to get my Bishop outside the pawn
chain try to do one or the other it
seems pretty uncommon just block I'm
fine with doubled pawns they're only
temporary
mmm Bishop d6 Bishop e7 Bishop d7 oh
let's just go with Bishop here not quite
sure what I'm gonna do with him just yet
okay so notice they've waited before
capturing and c5 waited for my dark
square Bishop to move maybe now I give
him a kick or just get on with castling
let's just castle they might try to
damage my pawn structure No okay so this
is an opportunity maybe take on this
square hmm let's go with this now maybe
they take on d5 first and then retreat
the bishop no so they're investing the
bishop pair I thought this was a moment
to maybe do this
it seems very awkward to place my bishop
like this but he's gonna temporarily be
bad let's get this bishop by the way
he's just target practice for Knight a 4
and maybe Queen to b8 as a move putting
pressure on the e5 Knight mm-hmm wow
it's not expecting that definitely want
to keep pressure on this and Knight here
and maybe now is my opportunity to play
Queen b8 or actually I think I should
focus on helping my LightSquared Bishop
to get working hmm yeah let's do this
I'm not ready to do this right away
because he stills a job of watching over
this pawn
huh rook to b8 hmm
I have to be careful of bad Bishop
versus good night situations hmm okay
what about Knight here I'm not quite
sure what that does I'm gonna look to
provoke a weakness actually yeah you
know I might be threatening something
like g5 as crazy as it looks yeah I am
threatening g5 and on f3 I'm going to
come back and then be threatening Knight
h5 I want to do something about this
tonight I wasn't so sure about Queen BA
because of 93 dark-squared bishop
exchange and then the Knights sinking
into b6 so I think a voluntary retreat
of the knight is a good move here just
welcoming a dark-squared bishop exchange
okay so they did go for that so it's
certainly a waste of time but this is a
weakness I should be on the lookout for
diagonal stuff and rank stuff in the
future taking here probably pawn takes
hmm maybe now is the time to do this and
cover b6 and maybe threatening e5 let's
get a pre move in there huh okay so also
I didn't point out but after c5 and this
now gives me a central majority probably
rook to b8 I gotta move faster defend
the bishop okay so now probably f6 to
get this in there's a big battle right
now going on for this five square so
maybe they take and then play e4 mm-hmm
it's gonna get sharp maybe okay they
took E for maybe I do this pawn takes
pawn takes and then they're hitting with
this okay hmm
rook to e8 or bishop here I think it's
important I play this rook here right
now because they're threatening to
capture and then enter on the seventh
and now I want to take a moment here to
make sure I could maybe get rid of my
bishop I'm gladly get rid of my bishop
for this tonight
he may very well be offside okay they're
avoiding that exchange now maybe I could
reconsider this advance yeah I think I
could go for this now pawn takes pawn
takes c4 c6 is no longer hitting with
the fork let's get him over here and
then here maybe Bishop c8 or actually I
could take the pun yeah that's very
important push here or maybe just
centralize yeah you know I don't want to
be too quick I don't think at least -
also my diagonals we can too quick to
give up the e4 square with the push as
tempting as it is to advance with tempo
okay what's that Queen up to try and
Queen trade here huh I could probably
improve my knight position Queen b6
Queen exchange yeah it's happening okay
let's do this and now my knight is going
to be a block hater very tense game
tricky Knights on board hmm I'd be
dropping this pawn right that's tough
hmm okay yeah I'm in a tough spot now
okay maybe I need to start pushing my
pond or actually this move yeah I think
this is important move on Knight takes
maybe I could do this and I'm Brooke
takes pawn I could take on c6 glad I
spotted that I don't know if it's gonna
be enough yeah highlighting something
that is deficient here huh okay yeah
this is big trouble hmm all right I'm
gonna play here I'm gonna grab this pawn
though all right huh
can I get away with this smooth there
knight is pinned actually they have this
check I can't take let's take now wow
this is going to simplify quite a bit
simplify quite a bit and I got to take
here they're going to have a two to zero
majority
got to do this and then get active with
my rook right here on the D file they
would contest it with rook d5 they
should cut off my king maybe I should
have played my king up okay yeah this is
this is gonna come at a snail's pace
hmm you know definitely not winning this
race let's get behind which pawn I guess
here and then here after rook there so
I'm gonna try for h5 and then let's see
how fast my king could be he's gonna
have to fly he ki might uh be generating
some threats it comes at a snail's pace
as mentioned we're gonna try for grab
this pawn actually let's do this
keep the rook really tied down under ten
uh yeah I got to get my King out of the
way where exactly um here I guess I
don't know I've got to start pushing
keep pushing
I got deflect the rook let's do this
might be a draw we're gonna see yeah I
could get this pawn and maybe this is a
key move hmm maybe I played that wrong
there oh yeah this is actually too easy
now for them King just comes over and
I'm actually not playing it my King
needs to be on CA
mm-hmm yeah this is this is gone
I needed to actually come to see a yeah
I should resign right here that's busted
mmm I wonder where I went wrong with
this one before I look at it with the
computer let me just have a look at it
actually let me flip the board yeah I
haven't I wasn't too pickin this move as
mentioned like even if they give up the
the doubling of the pawns is only ever
temporary because because of this
tension and to give up the bishop hair
yeah I felt like I was doing all right
right around here I wonder if this was
just a not a good idea this waste of
time
provoking f3 I thought it was okay
though hmm
this ending when it was two to one it
seems like those two pawns will just run
really really fast but ha yeah it takes
quite some time maybe I could have done
something I'm pretty sure I could have
done something better in that ending hmm
maybe pushed my F pawn I'm not at that
point yet in the game but her on on the
screen here but yeah we're gonna have a
look at this hmm I wonder right around
here and I don't know I think I have to
do something in the center now I have a
two to zero majority they have a passed
pawn though and hmm I don't know I'm not
quite sure what I could do better here
maybe this pawn was hit so I couldn't do
not here Queen b6 many of these moves
many of these continuations seemed quite
forced I have a lot of pressure on my
pawns now 85 yeah we get into a force
line and I think they probably even had
something better here I don't know this
seems very annoying a 97 move
not that but uh went in for this and you
know this ending will be interesting
they cut my King off I cut their King
off try to get behind the pawns maybe
there was a move I could have saved yeah
maybe I could have saved a move somehow
this will be an interesting ending to
check out hmm maybe this was unnecessary
huh I should take I should uh why am i
drawing lines like this I should take
this pawn on e4 get out of the way and
then push right away is it worthwhile to
save this Jeep on I put pressure on this
first and then took and then where to go
with my king
hmm I was down on time big time hmm at
this point but yeah I couldn't really
figure out what's Square to go to with
my king it's pretty natural to go in
this direction and maybe maybe I should
have done that have my King help out
yeah I mean cuz actually what did he end
up doing I wanted to be closer I went in
this direction I should be heading
towards these guys mm-hmm I'm not quite
sure what I was thinking by going here I
think it I think it was in my mind to
keep the King around to help out promote
this guy but yeah I think I think I
should have viewed it as you know I'm
gonna give this pawn up and this rook
will be diverted he'll have to capture
the pawn and then I get one of these two
guys with my rook yeah I think I should
have headed in this direction
d5 was maybe better and then push away
and maybe maybe another idea I don't
know it seems slow but if I could get to
the second again and then threaten this
f3 move taking advantage of the pin and
do some kind of a back and forth here
with the rook
hmm yeah the race it's a tough race here
and if I do something with this pawn
right now I wonder if I do this push
here here yeah it's now too slow this
rook no longer needs to defend a7 didn't
have time to calculate or anything but
we'll have to check it out with the
computer I mean before I even get to
this point of course there's going to be
an improvement come middle game which
was in my opinion quite an interesting
one with these changing of with the
changing of the structure so give me a
minute and I'll go ahead and pull up
stock fish okay
let's see where we can make an
improvement here you know what is
suggesting for white here just something
a bit more calm Bishop e7 check Bishop
d7 I didn't consider Bishop d7 but yeah
okay you know that would have been a way
to make sure I get rid of my bad bishop
well I don't know about make sure but I
could have at least offered the exchange
of light square bishop s' but this is
pretty even actually there was something
off here what about that Bishop e7 move
it likes Bishop d7 okay or to take on d4
first yeah to take on d4 prior to moving
the bishop I guess is another approach I
don't want to do that though I don't
want to capture and then give this rook
something to work with mm-hmm just keep
the tension I thought c4 and now wants
to go with Bishop d7 I castled I need c3
once you go with the bishop D D take six
Rd takes c4 at one point it popped up at
least I wanted to shy away from this
variation a situation where we have the
C and D files completely opened and I'm
still struggling to get this guy out
it's just - it's far too easy in my
opinion to play this on the on the white
side
you know the bishops are both
contributing contributing really well
the Knights are on fantastic squares and
the Queen is soon to move and both
Brooks will be really quick to occupy
these files while still having to get my
bishop working I wanted to avoid this
structural change I wasn't able to voice
it during the game though I don't with a
six and it wants to back up Bishop a4 I
wasn't tending to take but I guess they
take my knight and shatter my structure
yeah so I'm only temporarily up upon but
why could win it back with a 95 nice
centralization and both c6 and c4 hit
okay so that's something to be aware of
because one might view it as Bishop a4
oh I'm dropping upon but yeah this this
is a nice a nice way to invest the the
bishop air or the light square bishop
yeah one of these prongs b1 back and
still I'll have a structural defect one
of these C pawns okay so they took here
and I felt it was pretty even right
around this point yeah it is Bishop d6
c5 it does not like that was my first
impression but hmm wasn't able to really
capitalize or take advantage of this in
accuracy we might say oh I could take
that pawn I should have at least
considered that huh huh Bishop takes c5
and what would I do on Knight takes this
is my first thought C takes and then
rook takes mmm I don't know how I feel
about this position even material they
still the two-to-one majority hmm I
don't know I should have at least
considered though my first reaction was
to run away scared I guess I was
believing that this pawn was defended I
don't know directly or indirectly
directly
certainly because of a avert attack with
the night moving yeah I don't know if I
wanted to give up the bishop like that
should have at least considered it
though okay I backed up night a for aa
g5 for the moment popped up
isn't this where I played night at 94 no
I don't play 94 hmm g5 here only after I
played a 5 now this is you know this is
an interesting moment because hmm
it's like you know how do you say it I
mean let me try and get this exactly how
I want it here mmm
say it how I want to say it you know I'm
familiar in chess with the good and the
bad bishops and in this position he's
the bad bishop so around this moment was
I considering I was considering trying
to improve a piece some middle game
considering improving my LightSquared
bishop on the other hand I'm familiar
with what more essential majority this
is something that I have how do I know
which one to move forward with you know
it's like you're aware of two different
things the one idea would be to improve
the bishop one idea would maybe - one
idea would maybe be to set your central
majority in motion which one should take
precedence that's a tough question I'm
not sure now the computer is also liking
a5 only later did I have this idea of 94
and then the threat of g5 which is the
absolute most weakening of chess moves
huh this is I think this is fun I mean
it is calling for a5 Bishop a6 well and
it's only calling for a 5 right now and
in the variation it's showing
which you can't see it's it's not
popping up Bishop a6 anytime soon but I
imagine this is one of the ideas to
vacate the a6 square for the bishop and
also and also prevent b4 because I've
only mentioned I have a central majority
but what about white white has a queen
side majority of three versus two that
they could look to put in to set into
motion in fact they're already calling
instead of Knight a four it calls for
first b4 and if I am trying to play a
five to grant my LightSquared Bishop
access to a6 I imagine be five hits and
as strong and it is so this is okay so
even even though white one there's of
course still improvements for team white
here they could look forward to playing
b4 prior to this night a four move and
you know what that said you know this
idea of maybe g5 94 and challenging the
e5 square maybe that can wait maybe it's
more important to make sure the b4 move
is not hitting anyhow I don't know what
you want to make of that it's just it
that's where this game gets difficult or
wonder that one of the ways a chess game
gets difficult you're aware of two two
different ideas one related to pawn
structure or central majority it'd be
really nice to expand there and you're
also aware of a bad Bishop which one do
you go with I'm not completely certain
it's calling for a five on rook to e8
now but a five it was calling for we
might want to look into this first
because it interferes with what it is
white may very well want to do or ought
to do which is to set their Queen side
majority in motion so to go with the
plan that interferes with an opponent's
plan is maybe a direction to go
forward with all right anyhow we got 85
in sorry that was a mouthful but you
know just sharing what comes to mind
here rook to e8 and now it likes g5 this
is where I went with 94 with the
intention of maybe playing g5 in fact
when I played 94 I was only thinking
okay you know what he'll get kicked and
then I'll come back I didn't realize
that there was actually a pretty serious
threat in that of g5 hmm a bit blinded
to the g5 move I wonder why well for one
it is the most weakening of moves for
squares are weakened but yeah I could
hit with g5 recognizing that he has a
responsibility can't take because the
night falls although I guess it gets
pretty crazy and this is a very awkward
pin but anyhow g5 Bishop back Knight e4
would have been pretty interesting yeah
chop chop and then II 5 okay what an
interesting position this is well bishop
pair vs is the night pair hmm okay 94 f3
night back and night back night d7 I
played 97 fish up a6 hmm okay that can't
be bad either okay this is this is where
things are heating up here wants to go
with Bishop a6 right now I went with E 5
yeah I wanted to stop like 95 I thought
maybe if this 95 takes takes takes takes
yeah I wanted to definitely avoid this
scenario although although this is one
of those unique positions where it might
be the case that this night while really
deep in the black position he might be
in a way out of play but
that's not sure about that because there
is also some possibility of capturing
this pond and then maybe my bishop is
gonna be in some trouble I don't know
yeah you know I'm liking the white
position here very strong Knight mm-hmm
yeah I don't know I do I don't want to
give up my I didn't want to give up
these exchanges to have my knight in
dark square Bishop I don't want to have
a light square Bishop versus this night
I need four is the short story so plate
f6 avoiding too many exchanges the minor
pieces efore I think that's an important
move as otherwise just making it passing
them if I play e5 and then I'm always in
a position to me for with at least d4
and I have a connected past pawn and
white on the other hand does not have a
passed pawn something that they did
acquire in the game because their upon
it was able to exchange itself off for
my deep on and I was I was having to
recapture like this and there you go
they had a a pasty pawn so II for was
good I thought at least Bishop a6 I
played rook e8 it's fine this is what I
wanted to avoid the capture just making
a passing move I want to avoid this
stuff that seemed very uncomfortable
computers not sweating much though just
as Bishop a6 but this is very
uncomfortable not too human-like to be
playing like this but I guess it's
tactically there huh tricks like this
sure I'm gonna calculate that in a blitz
game okay rook e8 likes me
ever so slightly he 5 it does not like
huh yeah I should I could have
challenged this night physician huh hmm
too quick to advance with e5 yeah
because I guess in the end this is going
to be a favorable structural change
after E 5 I'm basically saying with E 5
I'm ok with allowing white a pass C pond
and I shouldn't be so quick to allow
that why not play Bishop b5 and force an
opponent backwards it's nice to move
forward and then have your pond reapply
and run backwards something is usually
gained with that and then e5 takes takes
and if this move it's a much different
story now I don't have to deal with the
knight coming into c5 or b6 very
interesting I like this game I like this
game yeah this is interesting ideas not
nothing nothing over one's head here
either
you know he's Bishop b5 first holding
holding off on e5 first inconveniencing
the night and only then pushing through
with e5 ok this is different now as c6
hits
let's go with the d4 did not consider
that d4 at a moment where this is
another okay this is another instance so
there's a little pattern here this is
another opportunity for me to move
forward and force my opponent backward a
little bit first she for the moment
cannot make use of c5 I get this advance
in in other words at a moment where
white is not able not not able to react
and move forward they can't go to c5 for
this one moment Queen d2 let's say Queen
c2 Knight f8 interesting very
interesting
okay I ran away it still holds as an
even issue position d4 I did not want to
play right away why do you know what I
was saying during the game I didn't want
to give up efore so quickly
it likes d4 though d4 Queen here 96 oh
okay this rook has a purpose I guess to
watch over b6 because in the end there
in this game what ended up happening the
Queen made use of b6 the Queen's were
exchanged and you know maybe it's better
to keep the Queen's on okay yeah this
seemed this seemed natural to meet rook
there with rook here not commit my d pun
right away but you know this is where
something's lost i should just set this
guy in motion hmm
what's one way I could have viewed this
move I'm tying one of my pieces down to
defending upon something to maybe shy
away from yeah I don't need to have a
rook supporting this it seemed natural
to just get a too centralized but this
is where I went to stray with rook to d8
Queen C 596 Queens are now off yeah and
this is a lemon rook to D 694 was good
what does it like better what's my
problem why am i not just pushing d4 and
I don't have an answer
okay yeah now it's a complete win for
white with nighties 92 c3 and I could
resign yeah because I don't get this
pawned back now okay yeah that would
have been a killer move just to defend
d5 we had this ending where it's only a
pawn advantage so yeah this is the last
thing I want to have a look at where
could I have improved here getting my
King active notice how it is even as
menacing as these guys look it takes a
real lot of time to get them moving so
this is a draw for how to make it a draw
it does not like King takes pawn now it
does I probably have to give it a little
bit of time here played rugby 6 King
takes e4 now Age 4 hmm I played King
here yeah and it does not like that this
is a losing move the decision to go and
this is where I did not I could not
figure out where to go and it does like
King d5 after the game I was pointing
out that this was maybe better to at
least had in the direction of the these
two connected passed pawns King d5 yeah
King F for no good and then was there
any other chance that I had now still +2
area yeah and this is not working out so
I'm down upon and I have the inferior
rook position be a different story if
these guys were switched yeah so this is
gone but uh hmm interesting in this
ending at least to go in this direction
you know I'm not quite sure what I was
thinking by going to f4 and yeah the
middle game position right around here
quite interesting these ideas with maybe
switching
move order gee 594 although not so sure
about that an improvement for white with
v4 prior to Knight a four and also yeah
not be so quick to allow this structural
change to play this Bishop b5 move first
force the opponent back and then
consider this advance and also later at
this point here playing first d4 this
ensures that my opponent has to move
backwards before I am reacting to this
pawn takes Knight threat okay
anyhow yeah I have no idea how long this
one went but it started out a well it's
a 3-2 game yeah this was a pretty long
video I think in the end but anyhow as
usual I hope you got something out of
this game and I feel free to leave any
feedback in the comments section below
that's all for now take care bye